بعد أن هزَّ العالمَ بضرباتِه الأخيرة، ها هو الإرهابُ يفرض على أعدائهِ الجلوسَ على طاولةٍ واحدة والبحثَ عن آليةِ تقاربٍ لتشكيل جبهةٍ موحدة لاستئصاله.
فمن كارثةِ الطائرة الروسية التي تحطمت إثرَ عملٍ إرهابي في سيناء، وتفجيراتِ بيروت التي خلفت قتلى وجرحى، وصولاً إلى هجماتِ باريس التي دقت ناقوسَ الخطر، وبين هذه وتلك اعتداءاتُ مالي وتونس، ناهيك عما يجري في سوريا والعراق.
مسلسلُ الإرهاب هذا يبدواً دافعاً لتجاوز الخلافات ورص الصفوف لمواجهته.
الرئيس الفرنسي /فرانسوا هولاند/ الذي يُجري مشاوراتٍ مكثفة لتوحيد جهود القُوى الكبرى في مكافحةِ الإرهاب، يَقْصد موسكو هذه المرة في محاولةٍ لتقريب المواقف مع روسيا للتركيز على أمرين أساسين وهما:
-تحقيقُ تعاونٍ دُولي أفضل في محاربة تنظيم داعش
-دُفع الجهودِ من أجل التوصلِ إلى حلٍ سياسيٍ في سوريا
جهودُ باريس تدعمها أيضاً خطوةُ الحكومةِ الألمانية بنشرِ ستمئةٍ وخمسينَ جندياً في مالي لتخفيف العبء على فرنسا في مكافحة الإرهابيين،
وهو ما يأتي ترجمةً عمليةً لتصريحات المستشارة الألمانية أنغيلا ميركل التي تعهدت بالتحرك سريعاً لمكافحة الإرهاب تجاوباً لدعوة هولاند.
وبالرغم من زَخْم الحَراك المبذول يحذر مراقبون من وجود خلافاتٍ هائلة قد تعيقُ التوصلَ إلى رؤية لتشكيلِ تحالفٍ موحد، من بينها:
-شكوكٌ في اقتصارِ التنسيق في مكافحة الإرهاب على هولاند وأوباما وحلفائِهما، ما قد يعني تمسكَ واشنطن بقيادةِ التحالف وهي التي إلى غايةِ الآن لا تملكُ استراتيجيةً واضحةً لمكافحة داعش، بإقرار برلمانيين أمريكيين.
-عدمُ جديةِ دُولٍ مؤثرة في المنطقة بنواياها في محاربةِ الإرهاب، وهو ما تجلى في اسقاط أنقرة لمقاتلة روسية وهي تدكُ مواقعَ الإرهابيين.. الأمر الذي وصفه الرئيس الروسي /فلاديمر بوتين/ بالطعنة في الظهر
-وأيضاً تلكؤُ جهاتٍ كثيرة في تبادلِ المعلومات الاستخبارية.
هذه النقاط قد تشكل اختباراً حقيقياً لصدق النوايا الدُولية في حربها على الإرهاب، سيما وأن انتشارَه باتَ يفوق تقديراتِ خبراءَ السياسة حتى وان كانوا حُواةً لها..